a 3d miss pac-man room and the RGB color
space Atlas is a book containing every
single color in existence Vsauce Kevin
here
this is my a kid in New Zealand recently
found a chunk of whale poop worth
$65,000 this rare substance known as
ambergris is excreted by sperm whale it
is used in extremely high and perfume
only 1% of the 350,000 sperm whales on
earth can make this stuff it's made up
of a fatty substance that protects a
whale's intestine and its nickname is
floating gold so yeah
allowing people to possess inanimate
objects with their bodies is caneta
using a kinect to basically animate the
world they scan a household object can
generate a deformation graph which is
like a skeleton for the scanned object
and this then allows this stepladder for
instance to animate easily along with
the movements of the human user
pretending to cook just got easier
thanks to this augmented reality cooking
simulator it calculates the heat
transfer from the pan to the meat and
vegetables being cooked and he even
simulates the weight of the food so it
feels realistic in your hand
the idea is to potentially use this
while cooking real food to guide
terrible cooks and whipping up the
perfect meal to pretend you have a chest
burster from the Alien franchise check
out this t-shirt it actually uses an
augmented reality marker or tracking
image on the shirt and an iOS or Android
app to bring it to life tuk-tuk-tuk -
tug toaster researchers at bionic Vision
Australia have successfully implanted a
prototype bionic eye 24 electrodes were
implanted behind the retina to stimulate
the optic nerve and right now the device
is designed to allow users to see the
contrast between light and dark shapes
and they're already working on a wide
view in
with 98 electrodes and another one with
a thousand and twenty four electrodes
Stanford researchers are testing a
special cooling glove designed for
athletes to recover from exercise
quicker than ever before
the palms of the hands are one of the
major heat exchange surfaces of the body
so by using a system dubbed rapid
thermal exchange they basically stick
this kind of vacuum on the athlete's
hand after exercising to quickly cool
down and recover the entire body the
system cools the blood not the skin so
it's not like putting an ice pack on
your hand would do the same thing yeah
I'll have another peanut butter and
jelly banana dog these amber droplets
contain the oldest bugs ever discovered
the preserved arthropods are an
estimated 230 million years old so
congratulations to this fly and two
mites for being the first insects
discovered from the Triassic error hub
bot is a polar bear robot that you hug
made by a Taiwanese company it's
designed to check your pulse when you
hug it for six seconds and they're
hoping to use it in elementary schools
and children's hospitals finally sue
Austen's freewheeling initiative
includes this incredible video of an
underwater wheelchair
I'm gonna leave you with a video of
proteins travelling through a neuron and
as always thanks for watching